hey it's me again first thing I want to
tell you is I don't drink and I don't
recommend drinking alcohol alright so in
this video we're going to talk about the
liver specifically how to reverse a
fatty liver a couple facts about the
liver the liver is about 3 and 1/2
pounds it's huge so on the right side of
your body goes all the way up here and
it's right through here ok it has over
500 functions it does everything from
immune control digestion detoxification
of chemicals building up of proteins it
does so many things it's amazing
miraculous organ it has 50 thousand to a
hundred thousand small little units of
cells that help do the work you really
could be functioning pretty good in your
body and have 90 percent of your liver
destroyed or dysfunctional so a lot of
times the liver will not show up until
greater than 90 percent of its destroyed
so you can't always go how you feel with
the liver but some of the symptoms with
a real bad liver issue is you get
bloating you have right shoulder pain
through here your eye whites of your
eyes turn yellow there's a lot of skin
issues pitching on the bottom of the
feet and the palms of the hand
basketball belly like your protruding
belly but you can really predict the
health of a liver by the person's
lifestyle habits so there's several
stages of liver damage that occur the
first one is from inflammation
inflammation where it could come from a
virus but it also could come from bad
eating or alcohol so every time you
drink it creates a trauma kind of a
whiplash because you're killing liver
cells when you're doing that every time
you take Tylenol or medication you kill
liver cells so it's as a lot of damage
even some of the medications like
lipitor for example will severely stress
the liver and increase the liver enzymes
by 500% so one of the big side effects
from the key
from the chemo the medication is
supposed to lower your cholesterol which
basically has everything to at the liver
ends up destroying your liver it's kind
of insane so you have an inflammatory
condition then you have fatty deposits
that lodge into the liver so over time
the liver can be replaced with fat many
people with bellies out to here have a
fatty liver if they just had an
ultrasound they would be able to
identify that but it's very hard to
detect chronic liver problems unless you
do a biopsy because it doesn't always
show up on a blood test so over time
when you have this inflammatory state of
continuing damage on the liver because
of bad habits you develop scar tissue
and that leads into something called
cirrhosis cirrhosis is the liver that is
filling up with a fibrous fibrous tissue
that's making it dysfunctional and you
lose the function of the liver but again
you can get away with only a small
portion of liver working before you even
notice a lot of the symptoms so just
because you are feeling it doesn't mean
anything all right so so that's what
happens with the liver when the liver
swells up because there's not a lot of
space it could the pressure in the heart
and create a lot of heart arrhythmia
tissues a lot of skip beats it can
create high blood pressure increased
pulse rate why because the liver is
right next to the heart and it's going
to compress in the heart when the person
sleeps on their left side if they have
an enlarged liver it will compress the
heart and make it hard to breathe and
sleep at night so liver cases tend to do
sleep better on the right side of their
body than the left but so that's that's
one thing secondly is the liver is the
one of the only organs in the body that
can completely 100% regenerate that's
the good news
the bad news is it takes a long time to
regenerate the liver of cells it could
take up to three years but I think the
worst recommendation for people is
everything in moderation because you
cannot heal the liver having a moderate
amount of junk food to the diet because
again
if you're drinking every night or every
other day or even once a week it could
take you 1 2 3 4 days for that liver to
recover and so you never really let it
recover so it's the accumulation of
letting the liver recover and heal that
helps it regenerate so it takes a long
time I had someone do my liver
enhancement program and they lost all
this weight but they called me up and
said dr. Berg your liver enhancement
doesn't work because I did it for two
weeks I lost the weight and then the
weight came back come to find out and
they're mine they thought they're gonna
heal the liver in two weeks that was a
miscalculation and they need to do it
for a lot longer until that liver heals
so so that's that's one thing so what we
want to do is we want to eliminate the
things that are destroying the liver now
alcohol is a probably the top thing that
destroys the liver and I do not agree
with so-called recommendations that you
can get away with drinking every night
that does not work
it creates damage on the liver I don't
want to get into that I think you're
already that's kind of common sense but
what I want to tell you is what to do to
get this fat on a liver number one stop
the things that are destroying the liver
and add the things that will create a
healthy liver one of the most powerful
things that will do it are the bitter
vegetables the ones that don't taste
good the most the more bitter the better
like the collard greens mustard greens
the kales the spinach is those are
really good for liver regeneration the
radishes are really good for the liver
and you have to start consuming those on
a regular basis so the other thing is
that the liver does not do well with
deep fried foods but it does need
certain oils the types of fats that are
good for the liver are the medium chain
triglycerides and what does that mean
like the coconut oils the coconut oil is
one of the best things as far as the fat
to cook in and to consume to help a
liver because it doesn't seem too
strain liver at all it takes the stress
off the liver the ones that distrain the
liver are like the corn oils that you
would buy at the store or of course the
hydrogenated oils those are really
really bad so we want a healthy liver
butter is actually a medium chain
triglyceride - so that would be okay to
consume and that takes the stress off
the liver so bitter vegetables the other
thing that's really good for the liver
to clean out some of the toxic waste
would be apple cider vinegar and some of
your water so if you take a teaspoon of
apple cider vinegar put it in your water
and consume that a few times a day that
is really good to strip off the fat off
that liver so as you can see these
vegetables over time that have a lot of
the B vitamins - I especially like
vitamin b2 choline full lay all those
key B vitamins that help deliver
regenerate over time the liver will get
better and better and better and better
but you're just gonna have to not drink
or not drink so much one of the
replacements that I like for the alcohol
would be the kombucha tea and get it in
the health of store kombucha tea is it
creates a similar effect to alcohol you
feel very relaxed and calm and again
people drink to relax so that would be
one substitute and it's really good for
the liver but the main thing is the
vegetables in this product I have it's
called the whole cruciferous food
I created a blend of the garlic tumeric
radish Brussels sprouts kale cabbage
parsley parsley has the most vitamin A
the most nutrition of any vegetable and
number two is kale kale is not quite as
strong as parsley but it's easier to
consume kale and the Cal shake so I
recommend a stat one Cal check a day for
your liver but this is a good
combination of cruciferous vegetables
that for those people that cannot
consume that amount of vegetables and
they need some supplement type help with
the liver so those are some tips on
reversing a fatty liver it's doable but
you have to take aggressive approach you
have to keep creating the liver give it
time have patient
that's what we call you a patient I'm
being sarcastic and so go ahead and do
that and I will see you in the next
video